معلم الموسكو الان السدمتريه على صحفي
والمحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ دي
متري هذا الخطاب لرئيس بوتين السنوي امام
الجمعيه الاتحاديه هناك تاكيد على الدواف
على التي دفعت يدن موسكو للقيام بما
تسميها عمليه عسكريه خاصه في اوكرانيا
ومبررات لمواصله هذه الحرب ما تقييمكم
بدايه لهذا الخطاب
هذا الخطاب هو خطاب مهم للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين هو تحدث فيه عن السياسه
الخارجيه الروسيه والطريقه التي سوف تسلكه
روسيا في حل المشاكل الاقتصاديه وبناء
يعني طريق اقتصاد جديد في التعامل مع دول
التي يعتبرها الرئيس الروسي
الصديق الي روسيا وبان التوجه القديم
لروسيا سبب مشاكل كبيره في التعامل
والتعاون مع الدول الغربيه ايضا هذا
الخطاب هو خطاب قبيل الانتخابات التي سوف
تكون في شهر سبتمبر من هذا بعدها
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الرئيس فلاديمير بوت
اتحدث عن ذلك وتحدث عن اهميه هذه
الانتخابات التي سوف تكون في شهر سبتمبر
وبعدها الانتخابات الرئيسيه التي يعني بعض
الخبراء وهناك مؤشرات تؤكد بان الرئيس
الروسي الذي مرفوطي سوف يترشح فيها هذا
الخطاب ايضا هو خطاب للداخل الروسي بما
يخص يعني الملف الصراع بين روسيا
واوكرانيا وما يسميها الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بالعمليه العسكريه الخاصه
هو يؤكد بان يعني هذا هذه العمليه
احتماليه هذه العمليه كانت كبيره بسبب
العداء الغربي لروسيا وبان هذه العمليه
لها تاثير كبير على مستقبل رؤوس الدول
ونحن مقبلون على هذه الذكرى الاولى لهذه
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وهذا الخطاب
كما وصفته وصفته
بمهم الى اي مدى هناك ربما دعم وتضامن في
الدخل الروسي لهذا الخطاب
اعتقدت يعني هناك جزء من يعني المواطنين
الروس الذين حتى الان يدعمون مواقف الرئيس
الروسي الذي مركوت بما يخص الملف
الاوكراني ولكن بكل تاكيد يعني هناك
تاثيرات كبيره اثرتها العقوبات الاوروبيه
على روسيا وعلى القطاعات الاقتصاديه
والتجاريه فيروس اثرت على رجال الاعمال
والشركات الروسيه التي بعضها غادر الاراضي
الروسيه وبعدها يعني يعاني من المشاكل
لانه كانت في السابق على هذه الشركات
تتعامل مع دول الاتحاد الاوروبي اذا هذا
الخطاب اعتقد هو موجه ايضا للداخل وموجه
للخارج بان روسيا قد تذهب لتجربه السلاح
النووي اذا ما ذهبت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في تجربه السلاح النووي اذا
يعني هذه هذا الخطاب قد يكون له تاثيرات
كبيره في الاشهر القادمه بما يخص الصراع
الروسي الاوكراني والعلاقات الروسيه
الاوروبيه شكرا جزيلا لاكاديميه الصحفي
والمحلل السياسي حدثنا من موسكو